النوويه التي تعتمد على مخزونات المياه في
سد نفاياكا خوفك في عمليات التبريد
اللازمه لمنع كارثه نوويه ويعتبر سد قناه
حيويه لنقل المياه من نهر الديني برو لشبه
جزيره القرم واكد مسؤولون ان المناطق
الشماليه مهدده بالعطش
وكانت السلطات الاوكرانيه اعلنت عن وجود
تسريبات زيوت محركات اثر انفجار سد نوفايا
كخوفك وقالت مستشاره مدير مكتب رئيس
اوكرانيا داريا في حسابها على التليجرام
ان طنا من زيت المحركات تسربت الى نهر
دينيبرو بعد انفجار سد كخوفك لتوليد
الطاقه في جنوب اوكرانيا موضحه ان هناك
المزيد من خطر حدوث تسربات اخرى تؤثر سلبا
على البيئه ومضيفه بان اهداف الروس من
تفجير السد وضرب القطاع الزراعي الاوكراني
وازاحه اوكرانيا كمنافس وابتزاز العالم
بازمات الجوع
من جانبه وصف السفير الروسي لدى فينا
ميخائيل اوليانوف في مقابله للعربيه اتهام
بلاده باستهداف المنشات النوويه بالامر
السخيف موضح ان المصلحه المشتركه تحتيم
الضمان امن منشاه زبروج النوويه
لا يحتاج الامر للتاكيد على ان كل الجهود
ستبدل لضمان الامن النووي والحديث بان
روسيا تعرض المنشات النوويه للخطر هو امر
سخيف نحن اسسنا الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه وبالطبع دائما ما نتعاون مع
الوكاله ونتوقع ان تتعاون الوكاله معنا
وهذا التعاون يحصل بصوره دوريه ومن ضمنها
حول منشاه زابوريا وبدوره اتهم السفير
اوكرانيا انطون كورن بيتش خلال مداخله
امام محكمه العدل الدوليه في لاهاي روسيا
بتفجير سد نفايا وصفها بانها دوله رابيه
لا يمكن لروسيا ان تهزمنا في ساحه المعركه
لذا فهي تستهدف البنيه التحتيه المدنيه
لمحاوله اجبارنا على الخضوع اليوم فجرت
روسيا سدا رئيسيا يقع في نوفا مما تسبب في
اجلاء عدد كبير من المدنيين واضرار بيئيه
كبيره وتهديد سلامه محطه النوويه ان افعال
روسيا هي افعال دوله ارهابيه معتديه
هذا ونشرت وسائل اعلام اوكرانيه صورا
بالاقمار الاصطناعيه لسد نفاياك خوفك
فيخرسون جنوبيه اوكرانيا قبل وبعد تدميره
وتظهر صور انغمار المنطقه المحيطه بالسد
بالمياه واكدت السلطات المواليه لروسيا في
خرسون ان منسوب المياه في المدينه وصل الى
اكثر من 11 مترا وتتبادل روسيا واوكرانيا
الاتهامات حول الهجوم على سد نفائق خوفك
الكريملين من جانبه قال ان الرئيس
فلاديمير بوتين تلقى احاطه حول ما حدث في
نفايا كاخوفكا رفض الكريم
عن تدمير السد واكد ان تدميره مرتبط
بفشلها هجمات اوكرانيا المضاد واضاف بيسكو
بان الهجوم على السد متعمد من جانب كييف
لحرمان شبه جزيره القرم من المياه
معنى من موسكو مراسل العربيه عبد الجواد
الرشد ومن دانيتك مراسل العربيه رائد
الاغبر اهلا بكم ابدا معك رائد ما هي اخر
التداعيات اجراء تفجير سد نفاياك خوفك
الحديث لي اظن لم اسمع جيدا عموما خالد
منذ الصباح الباكر والتطورات مستمره بخصوص
قصف السد وتدمير اجزاء منها الاجزاء
العلويه التي تسببت بفيضان المياه وتسريب
المياه ما تسبب
فيضانات على ضفتي النهر نهر دينيبرو الذي
يمتد في المنطقه الجنوبيه من اوكرانيا
ويفصل القوات الاوكرانيه عن القوات
الروسيه ومناطق سيطره الجيش الروسي ومناطق
سيطره الاوكرانيين الحديث عن ان هذا السد
يعني
غمر 600 منزل
ويعني في الضفه الشماليه التي تتبع لروسيا
وان عمليات الاجلاء بدات بالفعل الحديث عن
اكثر من عشرين الف نسمه تقطن في هذه
الناحيه السلطات
نشرت على
التليفونات
ضروره تحضير امتعه ووثائق
وطعام لمده ثلاثه ايام يكفي على الاقل
ولنقل المواطنين وبدات هذه العمليه بالفعل
عن طريق مركبات خاصه تنقل
تفضل
طيب يبدو ان الاتصال انقطع مع رائد اذهب
الى موسكو الى عبد الجواد الرشد
وسؤل لك ايضا عن اخر التفاعلات والتطورات
والتداعيات ايضا من وجهه نظر موسكو
مرحبا خالد على الصعيد الرسمي ان يتحدثوا
عن ان هذا الفعل بضربه محطه نظرك هو تخريب
متعمد ووصفته
الارهابي وتحدثت بان كيف ستدفع الثمن في
القريب العاجل بما يخص هذه الضربه على
الصعيد الرسمي في حكومه تلك المنطقه في
حكومه نظرك خفق المواليه لروسيا الحديث
يدور عن ان المدينه الان تملاها المياه
هناك انجراف للعديد من المنازل والفيضانات
طبعا تملا الشوارع هو معظم المناطق
السكنيه بالاضافه الى الاراضي الزراعيه هي
ضربه من العيار الثقيل لذلك الاقليم
الكثير من القرى والمناطق السكنيه
المجاوره لضفتي هذا النهر تتعرض الان
فيضانات في اخر الاحصاءات والارقام
الرسميه مستوى المياه في البحيره المجاوره
لمحطه زاباروجي النوويه وهو الملف الاهم
في هذه القضيه والاخطر ان صح التعبير
مستوى هذه المياه انخفض مترين ونصف المتر
تقريبا حسب روايه السلطات الرسميه هناك
المواليه لروسيا من المتوقع خالد خلال
الساعات الخمس القادمه ان ينخفض مستوى
المياه الى سبعه امتار ما يعني حسب
القراءه التحليليه العلميه للعديد من
الخبراء ان كانوا
فيروسات التقنيات العلميه في روسيا بما
يخص القضايا ومحطاء والمحطات النوويه بان
هذا المستوى مقبول لعمليه تبريد
المفاعلات في محطه النوويه لكن المخيف في
حال انخفض المستوى اكثر من ذلك الكثير من
القراءات تتحدث بانه يجب الانتظار هذه
الفتره وهي الساعات الخمس الست القادمه
لمعرفه ما الى اين ستؤول اليه الامور وكيف
هي الطريقه الافضل للتصرف وهل المحطه
بحاجه الى طرق تبريد في حال خرج مستوى
المياه على المستوى المتوقع الذي كان يعمل
به هذا بما يخص كل التصريحات الرسميه ما
زالت طبعا ما زال المواطنون من تلك
المناطق يقومون بنشر العديد من مقاطع
الفيديو والاخبار تظهر طوفان العديد من
المنازل فوق النهر الجارف هذه المياه طبعا
تاكل الاخضر واليابس هناك معظم هذه
التقارير تتحدث عن اضرار ماديه بالغه ولم
يتم التاكيد حتى هذه اللحظه عن مصرع اي
شخص خلال عمليه الغرق او عمليه الفيضانات
ايضا خالد طبعا حكومه تلك المنطقه تتحدث
بان هذه الضربه يعني هي فاعله بشكل كبير
وقد تؤدي الى اضرار جسيمه في المنطقه قد
تؤدي الى حرقه والغاء يعني ومنع معظم
الاراضي الزراعيه من الاستثمار خلال هذه
الفتره لكن لن تكون كارثيه على المناطق
المجاوره لذلك طبعا مدينه تاخيرسون حتى
هذه اللحظه وبالرغم من ان مناطقها
المجاوره للنهر مملوءه الان بالمياه الا
ان المدينه حتى هذه اللحظه تعيش وضعها
الطبيعي ولا خطر يشكله تدافع يعني
تشكله موجات المياه والفيضانات في تلك
المنطقه كل الاحاديث الان في الشارع
الروسي في الداخل على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي معظم البرامج التلفزيونيه تتحدث
عن هذا الموضوع تفضل خالد
ما حجم الاثر المرصود حتى في المناطق يعني
المحيطه بخرس
المتضرره الاكثر حرجا كيف ايضا تعمل
السلطات على الاخلاق اخلاء سكان هذه
المناطق
بدايه لابد من الاشاره الى ان الضرر يصل
الى مقاطعتي خرسون وزبروجي لان
السد في نوفيكا خوفك هو اطراف خرسون لكنه
يخدم محطه زباروجي النوويه والحديث عن
الهدف بقطع التيار الكهربائي عن محطه
النوويه بهدف تسريب اشعاعات نوويه حسب
المحللين في مقاطعه زابروجي ايضا السلطات
فيزا خالد قالت بان تعمد الاجانب
الاوكراني اذا تذكر قبل اسابيع قطع
الكهرباء عن هذه المحطه الكهرومائيه من
اجل رفع منسوب المياه من 14 مترا الى سبعه
عشر ونصف وذلك
ليسبب بعض الضربه ضررا اكبر
منازل والمقيمين طرف طرف الانفصاليين اذا
صح التعبير او الم لروسيا وكذلك الخنادق
الروسيه لان روسيا منذ اشهر وهي تبني تبني
خنادق دفاعيه اظهرت صور فيديوهات
المقاتلين الروس رغم الفيضانات
يحافظون على مواقعهم في تلك الخنادق التي
باتت غارقه بفيضانات النهر هذا من جانب
الجانب الاخر المحطه النوويه قالت السلطات
في زبروج والمسؤولين عن المحطه قالوا بان
المحطه معده
وجاهزه لصد حتى هجومات نوويه لو فكر
الجانب الاوكراني بقصف المحطه نفسها فان
المحطه مستعده لاي ضربه صاروخيه كما كانت
على الجسر فان هناك اتهامات متبادله
مستمره كما اسلفتم خالد وحتى الان لم يعرف
من قصف هذا الجسر وتسبب بكل هذه الاضرار
شكرا لكم من دانيات كوا عبد الجواد الرشد
من موسكو
[موسيقى]
هذا هو قد حضر الامير العام لخلفي الناتو
يانس من ان تدمير اسد نفايق كخوفك في جنوب
اوكرانيا يعرض الاف المدنيين للخطر ووصف
ستار استهداف السد بانه عمل شائن ويثبت
مجددا وحشيه الهجوم الروسي
لقد غيرت الحرب العدوانيه غير المبرره
التي تشنها روسيا ضد اوكرانيا بئتنا
الامنيه على المدى الطويل لقد مزقت روسيا
السلام في اوروبا واليوم يعارض تدمير سد
كخوفك الاف المدنيين للخطر ويتسبب في
اضرار بيئيه جسيمه هذا عمل مشين ويظهر مره
اخرى وحشيه الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات